what's up everyone it's Warren and today
we have some leaked photos from the set
of the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series coming to Disney and Plus that
reveal new characters coming to the show
some you may be very familiar with from
the comics and some may even go on to
join the Thunderbolts so really not
necessarily introducing a hero but
perhaps an antihero or maybe even a
villain depending on how the show takes
it so we're going to break it all down
but first I want to talk about the
biggest loss and Avengers endgame that
nobody seems to be talking about Captain
America's glorious beard why did he do
it I'll tell you why that time-traveling
son of a gun knew that he would see
Peggy and he knew that when he saw her
he needed to be smooth and not just in
the face but everywhere that's right
everywhere I understood that reference
why because he's a gentleman and as a
gentleman what did he use to shave you
asked well he used the lawnmower 2.0
from manscaped why because they're
refining the gentleman if you want to be
like Steve Rogers this Christmas you
need the lawnmower 2.0 ladies if you
want your man to be more like Captain
America he needs the lawnmower 2.0 it's
basically the next best thing to Super
Soldier Serum it's so advanced the
lawnmower 2.0 is waterproof it's built
with skin safe technology cordless USB
rechargeable its TSA approved and travel
friendly rust-resistant quiet safe
technology so it's not very loud shock
resistant and made with polycarbonate
materials and comes with a replaceable
ceramic trimmer head and as a subscriber
you get 25% savings on your order
instantly a new replacement blade refill
for your lawn mower trimmer delivered to
your door every three months making sure
your trimmer stays fresh and clean and
for limited time subscribers get not one
but two free gifts the shed travel bag
and the patented high performance anti
chafing manscaped boxer-briefs
this holiday season don't be normal be
super like Captain America your jingle
bells will thank you click the link down
below and use code cosmic 20 to get 20%
off your order
so the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
right now are filming in Atlanta and on
the set they have set up a stage and on
the stage is the logo of US agent now we
know that they're going to introduce us
agent and this could very well be his
introduction to the world however if we
look on the stage we can see a lady
with a pink mohawk now at first glance
this could very well just be a crew
member but if you look closely you can
see that she's connected to a stunt
harness so clearly she is a stunt double
or she's the actual actress performing a
role and as you can see there are
cameras on the set as well so they're
shooting a scene and there is one
character that could be specifically
connected to the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series and that is Melissa gold
aka songbird
now for those wrestling fans out there
you'll like songbird because she's a
part of the you CWF the unlimited class
wrestling federation which is basically
a wrestling group where bunch of
superheroes get together and wrestle
each other now after her time in the u
CWF she goes on to become part of helmet
zimas masters of evil and eventually she
becomes one of the Thunderbolts now we
have to remember and realize that Zemo
took down the Avengers by himself in
civil war he is truly an amazing villain
and this league today comes from Charles
Murphy and he states that he has to get
out of prison and there's going to be a
prison riot so according to him this is
how Zemo is going to escape prison and
even though Zemo took on the avengers by
himself and successfully took them down
he could possibly have some help in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series he
could be assembling his masters of evil
and songbird has been on many different
teams that Zemo has put together again
including the Masters of evil and the
Thunderbolts so it appears as if
songbird could be making her MCU debut
in the Falcon in the Winter Soldier we
also have some other leaked photos that
show us that actress a death row a
doughy has joined the cast of the series
now unfortunately without any content to
these photos we really have no idea who
she's going to be playing but we do know
that this series is going to dive into
the backstories of the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier so this could very well
be Sam Wilson's sister Sarah Wilson or
his girlfriend Lila Taylor we'll have to
wait a little bit more to find out about
what character she's playing but let me
know what you think about songbird
joining the MCU and would you like to
see x'mas masters of evil joined the MCU
in the Falcon and the Winter Soldier let
me know in the comments down below also
don't forget to subscribe what the
notifications turned on and like the
video so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 also
click the link in the description to
enter my Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
and as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fool